Halloween for a bro like the one night  of the year but we fit in what part and  moving the shadows don't you understand  I've never seen anything like this  before guys I got a lead on what's going  on  since its owner this would help us build  a know who's gonna be good  you're a rhinoceros and you're huh I'm a  little piggy  well  what's your name Casey Jones hey you  guys like a thing if the purple ooze can  turn humans into animals they could turn  us  into humans and we don't have to be  stuck down here forever if there's a  chance that make us human for turtles  whether you like it or not gear up guys  this isn't working we keep family  keep the team unified and you shall  always succeed  let's light them up  don't know this is such a good plan  never getting soft on me now  well